tu es canard teyssou savez christian
boltanski depuis qu'il crée depuis les
années 60 la mémoire est au coeur de son
art dans sa quête de figer l'instant il
a naturellement travailler la photo le
portrait surtout souvent d'enfants
s'ils voulaient ils sont tous morts tous
ceux qui sont là sont morts cette
période de leur vie est morte en tout
cas si vous êtes dans mon ce que
j'appelle mon on avertit si je puis dire
c'est comme ça immortalisée en photo
mais aussi à travers les objets
boltanski les expose parfois en vitrine
toujours en masse ses vêtements de frais
pu par exemple c'est à dijon en 1990 il
y avait quelqu'un il y avait une
présence mais qui n'est plus là c'est
sûr la présence et l'absence est avec
moi il ya encore là la forme d'accord il
n'ya plus le corps dont les années 90 il
théorise sa quête de mémoire des petites
choses du quotidien éloigné de la grande
histoire
il pose le concept de petite mémoire
qu'en mémoire et dans les livres
et puis la petite mémoire c'est de
savoir où sont les meilleurs qui chacun
à paris quelques histoires drôles c'est
ce que nous sommes et quand quelqu'un
meurt ce qui toujours affreux c'est que
cette mémoire disparaît totalement mais
cette quête ne serait-elle pas en leur
l'artiste l'admets en 2007 alors que
sort son livre la vie possible de
christian boltanski
l'art est toujours une sorte de
d c'est d'arrêter la mort et de saisir
la vie et de ses ratés puisqu'on aura
toujours donc on recommence le chat joue
on essaie de préserver quelque chose et
puis on sait très bien de préserver
christian boltanski s'approche de son
objectif en 2009 année où il annonce
qu'il se vend au diable cette année là
un collectionneur australien lui
commande une oeuvre singulière elle
consiste à filmer l'atelier de boltanski
en direct retransmettre les images dans
une grotte en tasmanie sur la propriété
de l'acquéreur et ce jusqu'à la mort de
boltanski
c'est mon avis le team puisque
évidemment ça va jusqu'à ma mort et puis
aussi que l'homme qui m'a commandé cette
oeuvre est un homme qui a gagné sa
fortune qui est immense en jouant au
casino jeux de hasard et il m'assure
qu'il est plus fort que le hasard et
qu'il ne perd jamais et donc tout être
qui ne perd jamais ou qui pensent qu'il
ne permet le diable forcément le fameux
joueur avait misé sur une mort de
boltanski en 2017
pari raté donc l'image de l'artiste et
ses oeuvres n'ont pas fini de dessiner
notre temps et d'imprimer notre mémoire
[Musique]